back with my Superstar pack I want to
read you a tweet from Kanye West it's
led to him being de-platformed from
various social media entities overnight
he said I'm a bit sleepy tonight but
when I wake up I'm going death Con 3 and
he spelled death d-e-a-t-h Con 3 on
Jewish people the funny thing is I
actually can't be anti-semitic because
black people are actually Jew also you
guys have toyed me and tried to
blackball anyone whoever opposes your
agenda uh his Twitter accounts now have
been removed his account's been locked
so Paul my question for you is twofold
really one is it right it has been
platformed and two when he says I can't
be anti-semitic because black people are
actually Jewish too what do you make of
this okay so answer to your question
number one absolutely he should have
been de-platformed what he was saying
was completely out of order completely
inappropriate broke every policy that
any normal natural Humanity human being
would want in place in terms of
protecting you in terms of any racism
prejudicism
um so absolutely right to have deep
platform team can I just add a b to that
this man is clearly not well why is no
one seeing this yeah I think people are
seeing it just heartbreaking you're the
last thing you've watched it yeah right
I'm listening I agree but Emily the
problem is he's got millions and
millions of followers on social media he
is clearly going through some kind of
episode I think from his behavior in the
last few days so is there a
responsibility there for the social
media platforms to make that kind of
judgment cool about people in the public
guy who might be having some sort of
episode
I think that's a very hard thing to get
into because then you're asking then
you're then you're asking them to start
judging what someone's mental state of
mind is so I don't is it right I think
because of what he said yes that is it's
purely anti-semitic
um I don't see how that if if they
allowed that through we can't then
complain when they allow sort of you
know we've just had a case where they've
met us being accused an Instagram of
allowing a young girl
about it you can't have one and not the
other just because he's famous Wilfred
we we actually had children at the same
school so we go back a long way
um and this Molly Russell case has been
very close to my mind with with the
Kanye uh incident actually because I do
think social media companies have got to
be a lot tougher now about what they
allow to be put in their in their
platforms because for example when I run
a newspaper if you publish something
like this in your new but you've been
serious regulatory trouble so it seems
to me they have no choice but there are
people all over social media today
saying what about his right to free
speech that if he was to say that why
can't he I don't believe in censorship
so this sounds very controversial but I
don't because one of the things that
struck me was the interview you did with
Andrew tapes right and I just think what
we need to do is that we need to trust
people to be making the decisions rather
than somebody else saying we don't think
this is good enough okay so let me put
you to the test right so imagine if I
started tonight's show by saying I'm a
bit sleepy tonight but when I wake up
tomorrow I'm going Defcon 3 on black
people okay so what I would what would
you say now hold on a second what I do
um I would say my edits I would say
right we're going to put this program in
and then you'll have an announcement
there there may be things in this
program that some people no I don't like
it I don't know well Twitter's live you
just put it up
D E F he said d-e-a-th that's a clear a
threat but but there are so I said that
about black people or for any type of
people but black people for example yes
I don't think your view about don't
censor it would have stretched that yes
there are but people know there are
certain people that's going to be
controversial they come and they're
going to doesn't mean they can say
whatever they want well that's not what
Free Speech it means when I'm not
talking about free speech at the moment
what I'm I'm talking about censorship
you will know that there are certain
people that's going to have a view so if
you decide to listen to that person
knowing they have a view well that's
your problem what I want to do is that I
want to leave it to people to make their
decisions rather than some of them that
means anyone can say anything they like
on social media is that your position
don't have it both ways you said
Nicholas sturgeon needed to dial down on
the rhetoric well yes but she's a
politician now we have this man she has
nowhere near as much influence exactly
exactly but do we know he has influence
with young black males because people
are it's a bit like Andrew Tate
and therefore people making decisions
based on whether this guy was talking
sense or not do you think most of the
people who saw an interview would have
thought this guy was right in their head
but Emily has come back to me on this it
seems to me this is a clear threat he's
making here we don't know what the
reality of that threat is but I'm going
Defcon spelled d-e-a-t-h-3 on Jewish
people I just don't think that should
ever be allowed in a public social media
platform and they're private companies
they can do with a like and I would
normally be hot on the case of
censorship that to me this is just pure
hate speech
I think it is I I mean not I think it is
and it that I I as I said earlier I
don't think you can have one rule for
one person because they're famous and
we're all sitting there going fine we
all know it's Kanye right not feeling
very well because then how can when
Molly Russell's dad took the case
against meta for why his daughter was
seeing these images which they believe
then led to her committing suicide
you've then got no protection absolutely
and so that that is that that is
it's really it when you have extreme
arguments it's very easy but you know
it's for me who decides what is censored
well I think I think I think anyone I
think honestly anyone that reads that
from someone like Kanye West that to me
crosses the line
to answer we decide to be racist
whether we actually listen whether we
watch rather than telling rather than
somebody says you are not allowed no no
I hear the point and I've argued that
many times myself there has to be a line
though there has to be alive and the
resides on the line well I think we all
know what anti-Semitism looks like when
you're making threats against Jewish
people and they've you know we know the
history we have laws as well that you
can't wander around the street yelling
racist or anti-semitic things so it
follows that Twitter which essentially
is a platform which allows you to shout
at lots of people that there's got to be
we're going to use those same laws in
place